hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I thought we'd do a quick
screencast it's a little bit easier to
follow along and we're going to answer
question from one of my readers Terry
who posted on my Facebook fan page in
response to a post I wrote about Ted
Turner saying if you can check out my
fan page give me some advice my business
how to keep it growing making a success
and it's drop it like it's hot wings so
this is Terry's fan page and if we load
it up we'll see here it is it's a
business based in Nashville Tennessee
and they have 225 people who like the
page so the first thing that would
recommend is putting a reveal tab on
here and this is basically where you
create special content or you put a
coupon or something to incentivize
people to want to become a fan of the
page and give you a like so in my case
if I load it in a different browser
where I'm not sending the facebook if
you go to my page you'll see this so
before you see the wall you'll see a
page here if you like this page now
you'll get steve jobs as number one tip
for entrepreneurs must help advice from
nine other famous entrepreneurs so in
order to access this content you have to
be a fan of the page and to do that you
have to click like we won't do that
because i want you guys that you go
through and check it out but basically
this is giving some premium content away
to people who become fans of your page
so looking back at your site if you can
offer some premium content or give away
a coupon or something extra special for
giving a recipe or something else to
make people want to sign up for the page
and it's basically the first thing that
they see before they hit the wall so to
give them an incentive to want to become
a fan the next thing I would encourage
you to do is try to post a little bit
more frequently so I'm loading on the
page here i see that you posted august
seventeenth and today is the 31st as i'm
recording this so it's been a while
since you posted and as i scroll down
here I see that you've got some fans who
are posting which is great so this is
yesterday yesterday an hour ago so it's
great that you have people who are
posting to your page and talking to
you but you haven't posted anything
really except for this post here so you
want to make sure that your posting on
an ongoing basis to encourage your fans
and make them want to get more engaged
with your site as well one thing that
really helps as I do it and the third
bit of advice is to ask questions so
when you're posting you don't
necessarily want to just say hey you
know we want to hit 100 likes you want
to ask some questions so ask them what
their favorite wings are asked them what
the favorite time of day is to eat wings
or how many times a day they want to eat
wings add some fun questions that they
can answer you know a couple words and
make them want to get involved and more
tied to your brand so couple of examples
of how I do this if we load up my page
here I try to post a couple times a day
and usually in the morning or do
something about a famous entrepreneur so
when when Terry found my page is
actually through one of the quotes that
I put up a famous entrepreneur Ted
Turner so a quote that he put about not
quitting go back to my page here so this
is today so I shared content about John
Johnson a quote from him so i'll do that
usually every morning and then in the
afternoon i'll also try to get people
engaged by asking them questions so
here's an example fill in the blank one
thing I did to grow my business today
was and you know 14 people love to
comment on it and it's usually quick
easy things that people can answer
without writing too much and it starts
getting them involved and then the next
time I asked them for something or if I
tell them about a cool link I've just
posted the more likely to click on it
because they feel a little bit more
engaged with the brand so here again is
another one a post that I created and we
had no six people seven people like it
in some comments going down a quote of
the day Lillian Vernon you know 99
people like it another question what's
your favorite food to snack on while you
work so it's a fun question that ties to
the brand of entrepreneurship and people
working but it's not you know so
specific and to Sirius that people don't
want to get involved so we had a whole
bunch of people leave comments on the
question like that so think about you
know post so you can put out on a
regular basis that is interesting to
people and then also
we'll ask them questions and make them
want to get more involved and more
engaged with your brand so give them a
reason to become a fan of the page so I
hope that helps Terry if anybody like
the video for all your YouTube videos
people watching out there please give it
a thumbs up I'd love to see it and help
me make more of these videos and it also
love to hear your thoughts and feedback
if you want to leave a comment below the
video and stay tuned for the next
episode
you